um let's go to where do we want to go
next let's go to the six one seven area
code six one seven what's going on where
are you calling from did you say this is
Austin from Boston no Oscar from okay
good
Oscar if we're on any kind of device
that might make it harder for me to hear
you please get off of that device
because we've got you maxed out and your
level is very very low is that better
that is much better yeah okay sorry
um yeah it was about media I kind of in
general with the way in which
independent media is growing
coupled with like more more people using
the Internet as us degress do you think
there would be a time when cable news
neither completely fizzles out and
becomes obsolete I don't think it'll
fizzle out I mean the the delivery
mechanism of through your cable box may
simply go away because it's irrelevant
as I mean already the lines are
increasingly blurred between what is
what what is receiving a news channel
via cable versus via the internet
especially when the internet and cable
signal is now all coming in on the same
connection into most people's homes
right so that I think that if your
question is this to the format of the
24-hour news network I think that's
going to be around for a very long time
as far as the delivery mechanism of
whether it's over the Internet or via
like what we would call a cable TV line
I think that that's more of a
technicality but I think the format is
going to be around right all right no
problem I like it when it's a neat and
tidy question and I can just give an
answer and that's that's where we go